[Music]
I'm going to try something a little
different I'm going to tell you a story
but it's a different kind of story it's
very short it only has three sentences
are you ready yeah he went to the store
Fred died Sharon went hungry and wept
now in listening to this story
what can you all tell me about maybe the
relationship between Fred and Sharon any
ideas did anybody think they were
married says maybe yeah so did you think
that fred was the one that went to the
grocery store did you think that so and
you also thought that the store that
fred was going to was a grocery store
right so in looking at this story I
didn't actually say any of that in this
sip and these three simple sentences Ted
interpreted some things that weren't
necessarily there now our brains are
actually hardwired to do this now
imagine that you're trying to convince
someone of your side of an argument
they're trying to explain something some
concepts of some way people may be
interpreting things that aren't
necessarily there so what's going on
here what can science tell us about how
we're interpreting this information and
how can we use that information to tell
better stories
our brains are predisposed to think in
story terms and in story structures this
impacts how we understand things how we
make sense of things and what we choose
to remember and what we choose to forget
these story terms and structures they
provide a sense of order to information
that's coming to us that's otherwise
disorderly
now Kendall Haven and his team of
researchers who are the leading
researchers on this topic they've done
an extensive amount of work and they
found that this story like structures
our brains are so accustomed to they're
the result of over a hundred thousand
years of evolution they've also found
the specific part of our brain that's in
charge of applying the story like
structure it's called the neural story
net and the neural story net has one
very important goal and needs to satisfy
the make sense mandates of our brains so
what does it make sense mandate it's
very simple actually it says that
everything we see and hear is to make
sense before we actually understand and
learn it pretty simple right things just
need to make sense before we learn it
but what's more interesting to observe
is how our neural story net actually
impact the information that we're
receiving if it's disorderly how does it
manipulate information that's told to us
in order to force it to make sense let's
take the Owens example he gave you three
sentences completely disjointed and
disorganized your neural story net
started making certain assumptions about
those three sentences in order to make
it make sense to you he went to the
store Fred dies Sharon went hungry and
wept you made the assumption that Fred
and Sharon were married you made the
assumption that the store was the
grocery store Phil didn't actually say
any of that
but you assumed it that's your neural
story net inaction that's they're
working to try to bring some connection
between these gifts disjointed sentences
now I can get worth in this if the story
being told you is so disjointed if it's
so disorganized your brain may have to
work so hard that it just decide type
let's disengage let's forget about
what's being told us right now it might
tell your body to splash back in your
chair you might tell your hand to reach
into your pocket pile your iPhone and
just play around on it forget about it
about class now look that's all well and
good if we're the listeners in the
audience if we're the listeners sure we
can distort some information and we can
make some assumptions we may even just
forget about things and play back on our
iPhones but what are the communicators
whether for the ones that meets whatever
the ones we need to send some very
important message to the audience which
we have a crucial message and we can't
let the audience disengage we can't let
them destroy our information if that's
the case that we need some sort of
strategy we need to come up with
something to be able to fit our message
into a story like structure because is
your job as storytellers to connect all
the dots for your audience
so Kendall Haven in all his research
he's come up with four major concepts
which governed how well a message is
delivered and whether that's a livery
fits into the story like structure that
our brains are accustomed to so let's
learn about those four major content the
four concepts are rooted in one beliefs
and that is the listeners ability to
make sense of our story directly impact
our ability to influence them so the
first step engagement now engagement is
on message guarantee influence
automatically but it certainly is the
first step to making it possible so what
is an easement engagement is our ability
to physically show up it's our attentive
focus on making sure that when we're
connecting with our listeners it were
physically being engaged with
no matter how complex and nuanced the
story is to matter how simple the story
is like Dylan's three seven stories we
learned in class is there a couple
different ways in which we can actually
physically engage through the use of
pauses or tone of voice our hand
gesturing our eye contact and our
posture transportation what we learned
of a mural the neural story net is that
listeners are constantly trying to
figure out what information we throw
away and what information we need to
keep to actually make sense of a story
being told to us what transportation
enables us to do as storytellers what us
joy tells us is it helps the listener
visualize and contextualize the story in
the plotline they're being put into and
that can happen in various formats in
class we learned through visual word
plays as one example to even mark mezzos
physically overtly bringing us and
transporting us into storyline as a
firefighter instead talk ultimately
transportation is aimed at building
trust between the story the storyteller
the narrative being told so with
engagement with transportation
ash will speak a bit more about how to
liver content is influencing so the
third point in this is elegant it is
self explanatory as JD says is a
understand your audience design your
intent and the knowledge of message
accordingly so your content has to be
relevant to your audience because our
mind has a make sense mended our mind is
constantly asking this question what's
in it for me
how am I related to the story if there
is no connection the mind can outright
please reject your message and do
something as cher said play with the
mobile phone or completely disconnected
but if you can make sense with your
audience
if you can stay relevant the audience
you can completely sell your idea
the fourth is influence this is the
whole purpose of his message this is
what you are trying to do with your
story you want to influence their
behavior you want to make your audience
to certain things in the way you want
them to do but is it the only behavior
that we want to address probably not
behavior is only a manifestation we want
to address these attitudes we want to
address their beliefs their knowledge we
want to alter that we want to create a
parallel stream of their beliefs that
okay what you're saying what you're
thinking Israel but let us think it this
way do not try to correct that do not
try to say so what you're saying is
wrong what I'm saying is I that doesn't
sell no you have to also really have to
define in new parallel stream so in
summary we talked about three things
today our brain analyzes every message
in story form if we cannot connect with
the story our message does not pass rule
number one message number two based on
if our idea makes sense based on the
make sense mandate in our brain our
message can be accepted altered or
completely rejected by our audience and
third we can crack good stories if we
follow a structure if we can stay
engaged if you can transport our
audience and place you where you want to
take them stays relevant and influence
their attitude beliefs and knowledge we
can craft excellent stories that can
influence our audience
you